this is Grandmaster Daniel narditsky we
are watching Sasha grishop taking on
Magnus Carlson at the 2014 fide World
Blitz Championship chrischok is one of
the strongest Blitz players of all time
he is going to be a very difficult
opponent for the world champion and the
game starts off with a Queen's Gambit
defense one of the oldest and most
reputable openings in all of Chess and
one of the most solid defenses as Magnus
Carlson is known for playing very
solidly in the opening and an
interesting choice early on Magnus
pushes his C Pawn up to C6 which leads
to What's called the semi-slav structure
so this actually isn't anymore a full
Queen's gamma decline this is now a
semi-slav but it's not a conventional
semi-slop either you don't see the dark
squared bishops get exchanged this
quickly in the semi-slav
all the time and who does that trade of
darksword Bishops benefit I think it
favors white black is now stuck with a
relatively passive Bishop on C8 but the
good news for Magnus is that his Pawn
structure is incredibly solid there are
no holes in Black's position and this is
just going to be a very very difficult
structure for white to crack in the
Blitz game and of course grishek as is
his reputation taking his time and
slowly ambling that Bishop up to D3
continuing his development and Magnus
does the same as he castles King side I
think rishik is going to Castle kingside
as well of course white could also make
the decision to Castle queenside move
the queen up to the up to C2 and then
Castle queenside but that just doesn't
seem to be grishek's style he prefers a
more solid type of position but I think
he's putting a lot of thought into the
prospect of castling Queen side here so
much so that he's already down a full
minute on the clock and he does decide
on Queen C2 but this is a good
Standalone move it attacks the pawn on
H7 it sets up the Queen Bishop battery
so this doesn't necessarily mean that
Christian is going to Castle queenside
but that is what's going to define the
subsequent course of the game which way
is white going to Castle is the battle
going to be positional or tactical
Magnus brings his Knight back from the
rim to F6 in order to defend the H7 Pawn
the Knight rejoins society and I have no
no doubt that white is slightly better
here White's got better control of the
center a more active position but the
hard thing about playing these types of
positions in Blitz is like I mentioned
earlier the fact that Black's position
is solid as a fortress no holes no
targets and grishek is going to have to
massage this position for many many
moves and Sasha now falling behind an
entire minute on the clock as he is want
to do which way is he going to Castle
that is the question you can sense the
wheels turning onto his head in his
brain and C takes D5 is his decision a
trade of Pawns in the center leading to
What's called the Carlsbad Bond
structure which is defined by the C6 and
D5 and D4 and E3 pawns and G for what a
decision by Alexander grishek as he
rumbles the pawn up the board and his
idea was to push G5 but Magnus preparing
for that by pushing his Rook from f8 to
E8 and the idea is to meet G5 with
Knight F6 to E4 and so grishook decides
to delay G5 and instead there is the
answer to the long-awaited question
Castle's Queen side you can sense that
it is blood which is on grishek's mind
here he wants to Checkmate Magnus
Carlsen on the king side but hey Magnus
wants to do the exact same thing to
White on the other side of the board
Bishop C8 to E6 by the world champion
completing his development and that
Bishop on E6 is not as passive as it
looks if black plays the move Knight F6
to E4 and something gets traded on e4
that Bishop on E6 is going to open up
some pressure on the A2 pawn and so
Grisha with his last move Knight G5 he
is trying to eliminate that Bishop he
takes it off the board and he softens
whatever blow black can orchestrate on
the queen side Bishop F5 is grishek's
phone follow up as he continues to keep
the initiative going on the king side
and he moves the pawn up to H4 and storm
clouds are beginning to gather around
black skin now grishock threatens to
push the Jeep on up to G5 and explode
the entire King side and if the H file
opens if white manages to open the H
file black is going to be in very very
serious trouble that Queen from C2 can
very easily get over to H5 it can get
over to H3 or in a future situation
Grisha could push his F Bond up to F3
and then slide the queen laterally from
C2 over to H2 so Magnus whatever he does
cannot allow the H file to get opened
and it's no surprise that he is taking a
significant amount of time here to
decide how he wants to deal with White's
King side attack and there's our answer
Knight F6 to E4 precipitating a trade in
the center grishook takes on e4 with his
bishop and there's that G5 move and I
guess is that Magnus is going to meet
that with H5 and he does indeed but
Grisha he pushes the pawn up to G6 he is
not to be denied he insists on ripping
the king Side open Knight D5 is an
excellent defensive response by Magnus
that knight from D5 is threatening to
jump into B4 and then infiltrate that D3
Square which is anchored by The Pawn on
e4 if the pawn on e4 is to be captured
here the night before comes with even
more unpleasant effect because White's
Queen is then going to have to stay
pegged to the E4 Knight so it's going to
have to drop back to B1 leaving the
white king incredibly exposed I don't
think Grisha can take the pawn on e4
he's already down to 30 seconds on the
clock it's time to make a decision and
yes he does take the pawn any four what
a bold call by Alexander grishaken my
guess is that he's actually going to
move the Knight and he does nitrified by
Grisha that is the only saving resource
and Magnus you could sense the
frustration and that forces a queen
trade Knight takes C2 Knight takes F7 a
mutually assured destruction both Queens
are off the board and Magnus noticed
that intermezzo the knight from C2
before disappearing off the board
sacrificed itself for the E3 Pawn that's
called a Desperado move that restores
the material equality
and now we have on our hands a four Rook
end game a double Rook end game where
both sides are desperately trying to
activate their Rooks Magnus doubling on
the e-file and grishook moving his Rook
up to H3 that Rook on H3 is a hero it's
defending both of White's weak pawns on
E3 and H4 but it is amazing that Magnus
has managed to get this into an end game
at one point after grishek moved his
pawns up to G4 and H4 it looked like
mate was inevitable and now Sasha is one
and it's hard to even say he's 90
seconds down on the clock but we know
how incredible Grisha is with his last
seconds taking off his clock and he
pushes up to B4 make no mistake
Alexander grishock is still very much
playing for a win he's got that Ultra
active Rook sitting pretty on D6 and
right now his strategy is to push his
Queen side pawns up which is exactly
what he's doing A4 threatening B4 B5 and
if Grisha trades magnus's C6 Pawn off
the board then the D4 Pawn is going to
become a protected past Pawn but is
grishek willing to sacrifice a pawn in
order to achieve that oh he's got five
seconds to decide and he decides with a
yes B5 is on the board and he does
sacrifice the pawn but he's insisting on
making that sacrifice temporary Rook B6
and he's going to recover if he wants
the pawn on B5 but instead he plays Rook
G3 harassing the pawn on G6 and forcing
Magnus to give the lateral checks a
repetition of moves here is very likely
grishock doesn't mind a drug he's got 10
seconds on the board or does he will he
play King E1 no he goes King D3 and now
it's up to Magnus to decide whether he
wants to repeat the move now in Blitz
you cannot claim a three move repetition
even though the position has been
repeated three moves because neither
side is keeping score so there is no
proof unless an Arbiter is watching that
the position has been repeated it's a
fascinating rule in Blitz and the sides
continue to repeat moves but finally
grishook is the one who deviates he was
thinking on magnus's time and he decides
that with 11 seconds he still wants to
play for a win what a gutsy call by
Gresham but I think the game is still
very likely to end in a draw because
Magnus has snagged the pawn on E3 and
the black king is surrounded by that
defensive cocoon composed of The Rook on
E7 I don't think black's King is under
any danger Rook takes H5 Rook takes D4
both sides liquidating each other's
pawns and now all that both sides have
left is just one Pawn Magnus still needs
to be careful Black's King is in a
little bit of danger a little bit of hot
water but those black Rooks are doing
such a capable job of keeping the king
well protected and now grishek sees no
alternative but to slide his King up to
B5 and now I think the result of the
game is no longer in question let's see
how Magnus navigates the last couple of
moves here and navigates them well he
moves his King all the way from the King
side to the queen side what an
interesting storyline black skin started
on the king side it was under tremendous
duress and it ends the game as the sides
shake hands and agree to the peace
treaty on the queen side surrounded by
his Pawn a phenomenal defensive effort
by Magnus and a great attacking effort
by grishook if you like this video make
sure to click the link in the playlist
thank you so much for watching
foreign